today it's all about street food so
there'll be general rejoicing in the
house because my kids absolutely love it
whether it's asian noodles mexican tacos
or even american fried chicken trust me
street food is fast to serve fun and
packed with flavor and that's what makes
it so easy to cook at home
first up for breakfast a classic from
the streets of india designed to be
eaten on the go but brilliant devoured
in the comfort of your own kitchen
incredible indian spiced egg and spinach
wrap it smells incredible
next is lunch and my take on two street
food essentials
perfect prawn tostadas and salted
caramel popcorn that's impossible to
resist
beautiful
for dinner my son jack helps cook one of
his all-time favorites
nice nice see i put some house on your
chest boom it's working already home
cooked street food that will have
everyone racing indoors to sit down and
eat
delicious dolce de leche biscuits quick
sweet pickled celery and amazing
buttermilk fried chicken
i love
fried chicken i love it more than you
did
this is my ultimate street food
breakfast lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast and eggs
guaranteed to spice up your day
some of the best food i had in india was
street food and
every little food stall
was cooking up something spicy something
delicious
a little teaspoon
of oil gonna toast off
a teaspoon
of cumin
mustard seeds
a touch of salt
and pepper
lightly fry them off
it's really important to cook off the
spices it intensifies the flavor but
really draws out that nice spicy deep
rich flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind nice and fine
onions in
[Music]
now
we're gonna caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have
started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there
get it nice and sort of rich gas up nice
and high
and really caramelize those onions now
once the onions have turned a rich
golden color that's what i'm looking for
that is beautiful
add baby spinach
keep that pan nice and hot
if you don't cook it out
the actual breakfast ends up watering
when the spinach is cooked set aside and
it's on to the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alight
four nice eggs
now give those eggs
a little whisk a little touch
of butter
into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot add a
teaspoon of garam masala and turmeric
cook that out
now
take your eggs into the pan
almost gonna make
like a really nice spicy scrambled egg
turn the gas down
now as the scrambled egg comes together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter
i quite like the sort of creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there
i get my spinach
chop up
and then fold in
the spinach
to a scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast but it's served in
these wonderful little
thin naan breads
this will work with any flatbread or
wrap you fancy and then lightly toast
your naan take the eggs off the heat
whilst you get on with the last job add
quick mint and spice yogurt dressing
a couple of tablespoons
of fresh yogurt in
there's always something to take out the
heat then add chopped mint
salt and turmeric
mix that in
now
take
the scrambled egg and half fill
and now
it smells incredible get your yogurt
down on top
and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food in india
how delicious they can make street food
with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
once you try this spicy wrap i promise
you scrambled eggs will never taste the
same
[Music]
up i'll be showing you some irresistible
street food dishes that are brilliant
cooked at home
but first here's a closer look at some
of the ingredients you'll need to buy to
make them
starting with tortillas for lunch
when it comes to street food the
mexicans have got it nailed tortillas
turn any dish into a portable feast
the yellow ones are made from corn flour
white ones from wheat
i'm going to toast a wheat tortilla for
the incredible prawn tostada i'm making
for lunch
[Music]
paprika originates in hungary where it's
been sold on the streets for half a
millennia
made from dried ground peppers ranging
from sweet bale to mild chili peppers it
could be sweet or hot but it's the
incredible smoked paprika i'm using for
my secret fried chicken recipe
everyone loves popcorn and it's
incredibly easy to make
it's just the dried kernels from corn in
the cob it comes in loads of different
colors and varieties
good old yellow is the one we know and
love whilst red is slightly nuttier and
white gives a fluffier mild flavoured
corn taste
on the menu next for lunch is my take on
this street food classic
one of the reasons i love cooking street
food at home is because it's such a
contrast to what i do in my mission
style restaurants on a daily basis a
little bit of salt on top as well yeah
it's not about intricacy or complexity
that's all gone out the window and trust
me there's only one rule if it tastes
great
cook it here's my ultimate street food
lunch succulent zingy prawn tostadas and
for dessert salty caramel popcorn so
good you'll want to eat it by the
handful
you can't beat
properly home-cooked popcorn
start off with just a touch
of oil in there as it lightly starts to
smoke
corn in
so now get your lid never leave it far
away from you
sounds like it's raining it's not
so it's popcorn canals trying to pop out
boom
delicious
just a little shake of the pan get it
going
and then lift that lid
at your apparel
we
see
it's a very exciting pan in there
and when all that little pitter patter
stops you know your popcorn is cooked
nice
you could eat it fresh from the pan but
i've got another plan
i'm gonna make a salted caramel popcorn
start off with your sugar into the hot
pan
never stir a caramel otherwise it
crystallizes it's a salted caramel so a
nice pinch
of salt in there as well
now once you've got it to a really nice
dark caramel flavor stir in your butter
very carefully caramel is very very hot
half a teaspoon of bicarbonate of soda
kickstarts the reaction that gives the
caramel a honeycomb flavor
mix that in
you'll see it
reacting
almost like a large crunchy
in the bottom of your bowl
now the gas is off and that caramel has
a nice dark rich
flavor
now pour in the popcorn to coat it with
that incredible caramel give that a good
mix
it's that easy and it's gonna taste
amazing
lay that nice and flat
once that cools down it becomes nice and
brittle we've got that nice salted
caramel flavor which just takes popcorn
to complete dim level whilst the popcorn
cools down it's on to my prawn tostada
wonderful prawns
gonna marinade them first with a little
bit of garlic
nice and fine
[Music]
and don't worry if you can't slice
thinly just
get a little crater and grate the garlic
nice and fine as well nice pinch of
chili flakes over your prawn garlic in
salt
pepper
and olive oil give that a really nice
little mix
whilst the prawns marinade i'm gonna
knock up a salad this is a really nice
sort of light fragrant salad radishes
topped and tailed and then into quarters
cherry tomatoes halved
spring onions sliced
and seasoned
and then
just to liven things up a little bit of
chili in there and slice them on an
angle
now the avocado cut in half
give that a little twist
so you just go down
and down and down carefully with your
knife turn it round
go down and down and down and then
you take your spoon and you've got your
diced avocado
coming out already
now baby gem lettuce half then
shred freshly squeezed lime juice and a
little drizzle
of olive oil tostada is a classic
mexican style open tortilla so
that lime complements it beautifully
lastly roughly chop coriander and give
it a mix that is the perfect base
for our tostada the salad's ready now
for the prawns and don't be afraid of
getting the pan nice and hot
teaspoon of olive oil in
anything less than that sizzle when you
put that first prawn in there don't put
them in keep them nice and flat
make sure you've got all that marinade
in there as well watch them change color
rapidly i'd rather cook them
quicker in a hotter pan
and slower in a colder pan the
difference in taste is night and day
the prawns will take just two minutes to
cook through
lime juice just over the top
nice
toss them over the lime
these are
corn
tortilla quite robust
and there's a kind of base that doesn't
disintegrate hot pan
in it's a dry pan
so
that corn tortilla goes nice and crispy
on the outside
[Music]
look
crispy shell
to build them generous with the salad
that base will stay nice and crisp
next
with your prawns i like to keep the
tails
in to the center
and lay the round
part of the prawn on the outside
and there we have
a delicious yeah very humble prawn
tostada followed by my superb salty
caramel popcorn
beautiful
[Music]
prawn tostadas and salty caramel popcorn
vibrant irresistible smelling dishes
you'll want to dive into
over the past 20 years i've really
noticed a big change in people's
attitude to what they will and won't eat
[Applause]
these days people are much more
adventurous they love trying new flavors
new ingredients and new cooking
techniques
whether it's cooked on the street or in
your home kitchen this is my ultimate
finger licking street food dinner
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen to make
one of his all-time favorites is my son
jack
first job the perfect side dish for my
fantastic fried chicken
jack
am i gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely now you love
pickles right love pickles um favorite
pickle what is it i like pickled onions
we're going to do pickled celery it's a
nice little snack and great for plum
ones great for salads first thing i want
you to pick the celery for me so you see
where the next one's gonna be it's in
there yeah okay i'll figure out well i'm
hungry today is this all we're having
for dinner jack come on i wouldn't do
that too you know that there's more
coming now because we're
pickling it
we want to sort of make it look
a little bit more attractive so we go
around like that
okay on an angle
so when you pick all the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also it gives it a really nice
salty
soury flavor yeah okay now splash of
water and then with the sugar nice okay
so we've got to bring that up to the
bowl
and sort of create
almost like a little syrup yeah okay
little teaspoon of peppercorns in
mustard seeds in quite generous on the
mustard seeds that gives a bit of sort
of spice now those you must know
cloves excellent cloves
in
now touch your salt in there
okay
so from there white wine vinegar
now
in order for all that to actually
pickle
you need to boil it
so by boiling it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together it fuses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
nice nice see i put some hairs on your
chest
yes it was good look boom it's working
already now see
nice
vinegar
right celery's ready yeah okay let's
walk to the ball now
turn that off
now
from there
start placing the celery
into that jar so when you pick other
foods can you use that same recipe
exactly that
100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off
okay now put them in there so can we eat
this straight away when it's in here do
you know what as soon as it's cooled
down
you can definitely eat that straight
away can't wait to dig into it at dinner
are they delicious yes we'll leave that
to cool down
our pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken when you fried
chicken traditionally it's always gonna
be done with the dark meat the brown
meat so you've got that nice sort of uh
drum
here and this bit
that thigh cooking on the bone as well
keeps it even more moist so first things
first salt pepper
please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinating the
chicken if you can put this buttermilk
over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax the chicken and puts a really nice
sort of creamy soury flavor in there so
might stick that in the fridge for us
please and we'll start the dolce de
leche biscuits
nice the argentinians call these
shortbreads alfa jorge and they're the
favorite sweet treat on the streets of
buenos aires
they're light crumbly shortbread
biscuits sandwich with gloriously golden
caramelly dolce de leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar
and beat until light and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
slice vanilla pots
scrape out the seeds add to the mix
and beat again
[Music]
sift plain flour
corn flour
and baking powder
then fold the mixture together
using floured hands roll into small
balls
flatten into discs and place on a baking
tray
[Music]
chill for 10 minutes until firm to touch
then simply bake for 10 to 12 minutes or
until pale golden
once cooled
sandwich two biscuits together with a
caramelly dolce de leche sauce
[Music]
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
[Music]
delicious
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken all that's left is to fry
it
now we're going to
roll the chicken
out of the buttermilk into the flour so
that's why it gets nice and crispy and
blistery on the outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yes
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice
and this
is smoked paprika
so that gives it a little bit of sort of
uh
making yeah yeah spice that's right a
little bit of heat and that's one of my
favorites what's that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please cool i'm gonna get the pan
on now
two centimeters
of oil this is a really good mix for
fish as well
gushons biting
a nice spicy
texture
helps fish so first thing
is we just shake off some of the
buttermilk lay that down yes okay really
important to get them covered completely
okay
in the flour yeah okay
so i love fried chicken do
now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you off you
go nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yeah just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
good
gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through
now very carefully turn them over please
yeah cool
can we have this every day
jack fried chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah
now off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay onto the
paper
sell them
i love
fried chicken i'm telling you i'm pretty
sure i love it morning look here's the
best bit
delicious now
fried chicken
are pickles if you pick up um dulce de
leche cakes we are ready bud very nice
that's good
delicious uncle mummy wow tilly phoebe
rum
divine dolce de leche biscuits my
pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken a soulful street food feast if
there ever was one
and joining the ramsay clan tonight is
tilly's schoolmate phoebe
now first of all we have some very very
exciting pickled celery phoebe and i'll
have a drum please here we go nice
ladies you can lift it up with your
fingers especially on the drums that's
good because i can't do this
finger licking chicken that's right baby
how's the chicken
amazing i wouldn't be able to like make
this at all yes you would yes you will
it's so easy to make you see yourself
it's very easy to make right
dad did say we could have it every night
in the week
what i said as a treat
it's chicken so it's healthy right you
always take you always tell me to eat my
chicken well chicken is healthy but not
fried every night okay
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
know what phoebe's favorite show is
what's phoebe's favorite show
tell me
um well sometimes i watch jamie oliver's
15-minute meal
sometimes you watch jamie all of those
15-minute meals this is 15 minutes so
freebie
taxi's here
you